and we're following some breaking news
already this morning there is another
possible bomb that was found in New York
as the FBI intensifies its investigation
of a series of devices sent to critics
of President Trump take a look at these
pictures they have are of an NYPD bomb
truck transporting the latest suspicious
package to a safe location now it was
sent actor Robert DeNiro at a New York
production house sources say it
resembles at least eight other devices
that were found in four states and in
Washington DC now most of those were
sent to prominent Democrats including
former President Barack Obama and former
presidential candidate Hillary Clinton
and CBS News has just learned that
another one was sent to former Vice
President Joe Biden
the FBI says at least three of the
packages contained the pipe bombs
none of them exploded and no one was
hurt president Trump responded during a
speech last night any acts or threats of
political violence are an attack on our
democracy itself no nation can succeed
that tolerates violence or the threat of
violence as a method of political
intimidation coercion or control Jeff
PJs is tracking this investigation he's
outside the Obamas home in Washington DC
Jeff good morning what's the latest and
good morning the response that we are
seeing right now in New York is similar
to response we saw yesterday with the
NYPD bomb squad and bomb truck moving in
to take control of a suspicious device
it certainly feels like this
investigation is expanding by the minute
with all of these suspicious devices in
this morning this federal task force is
racing to track down whoever is
responsible
one day after first responders and bomb
squads swarm locations across the
country an intense investigation is
underway into who sent a series of crude
explosives two prominent public figures
and the press we wouldn't be at all
surprised if more devices show up in New
York City investigators are combing
through surveillance video in and around
CNN's offices after a suspicious package
was delivered addressed to former CIA
director John Brennan it appears that an
individual or individual sent out
multiple similar packages Wednesday law
enforcement uncovered another package at
a postal facility in Los Angeles one of
two addressed a Democratic congresswoman
Maxine Waters investigators have also
recovered suspicious packages addressed
to Hillary Clinton President Barack
Obama and Democratic Party mega donor
George Soros a package intended for
former attorney General Eric Holder
ended up Wednesday at Democratic
congresswoman debbie Wasserman Schultz's
office in Florida because of a phony
return address the federal government is
conducting an aggressive investigation
and we will find those responsible and
we will bring them to justice
x-ray images obtained by the New York
Times show a recovered pipe bomb one of
which law enforcement sources tell CBS
News was made from PVC tubing containing
explosive pyrotechnic powder and glass
to be used as shrapnel a digital clock
connected to a small battery served as a
possible triggering device at least four
of the packages were sent using manila
envelopes with six American flag forever
stamps on each one they'll now be
analyzed at the FBI laboratory in
Quantico Virginia as they're gathering
this information all these investigators
how does that information filter up to
the top what markings are on the outside
or on the inside of a piece of end cap
to see who's the manufacturer Ron Hosko
is a former assistant director of the
FBI what does it say that they didn't
explode well it may say that that they
were intercepted prior to their ability
to explode it may say that they were
never capable of exploding even though
they may have had black powder in the
you can put black you can put right now
investigators are working under the
assumption that whoever built these
suspicious devices tried to keep the
weight down so that they could just drop
them in a mailbox rather than going to a
post office and risking getting caught
on surveillance cameras they believe
these devices were functional but
because they did not explode
investigators will be able to
deconstruct the devices and then try to
trace the components John Jeff thank you